Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zu Ausgabe 89 unserer Gesprächsreihe
und heute hat mich der Weg nach München geführt und stellt mich in gewisser Hinsicht auch für eine doppelte Herausforderung.
Denn einerseits möchte ich über Mathematik reden und das ist, glaube ich, generell schon mal eine gewisse Herausforderung.
Auch wenn wir das hier schon mal getan haben.
Und wir werden auch viel über Visualisierung sprechen.
Und auch das ist ja ein bisschen knifflig in einem Podcast.
Nichts desto trotz, ich bin zuversichtlich, dass mir das gelingen wird mit meinem Gesprächspartner,
nämlich Jürgen Richter-Gebert, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, ich freue mich hier zu sein.
Ja, Herr Richter-Gebert, wir sind hier im Lehrstuhl für Geometrie und Visualisierung, richtig, an der TU München.
Ganz genau.
In Garching, in diesem Forschungszentrumsbereich, wo auch noch sehr viele andere sehr interessante Organisationen ihr Heim haben.
Und das Ganze ist natürlich der Mathematikteil.
Ist das eigentlich mit der Informatik zusammen die Bereich in der TU München?
Wir sind zumindest im selben Gebäude drin, das heißt, die eine Hälfte vom Gebäude ist die Mathematik, die andere Hälfte ist die Informatik.
Und in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft sind wir sogar in einer Organisationseinheit zusammen,
weil die TU im Moment umstellt und Fakultäten zu Schools zusammengefasst werden
und dann sind wir dann nach außen hin eine Fakultät sogar.
Okay.
Oder eine School, besser gesagt, für Computation, Information, Technology.
Und ist das eine begrüßenswerte Tendenz?
Ist das etwas, was, sagen wir mal, naturgemäß gut zusammenpasst, weil hier sowieso schon viel zusammen gearbeitet wird?
Also Mathematik und Informatik gehören natürlich irgendwo zusammen.
Letztlich ein großer Teil der Informatik ist aus der Mathematik raus entstanden
und die Mathematik bedient sich immer wieder der Informatik, um die verschiedensten Dinge zu machen, meistens die coolsten Dinge zu machen.
Und von daher es gehört irgendwo zusammen und man sollte es auch in dem Verständnis zusammen pflegen.
Wird natürlich nicht von jeder Person in gleichem Umfang gemacht, sowohl auf der einen als auch auf der anderen Seite.
Aber Potenzial hat das, jede Menge.
Das Thema greifen wir noch mal auf, aber ich würde gern zu Beginn, wie es hier so meine Art ist,
vielleicht erst mal so ein bisschen in Ihre Vita einsteigen und mal so rausfinden, wie es denn hier eigentlich dazu kam,
dass wir jetzt hier zusammen sitzen.
Ich ahne ein Liebe zur Mathematik, die früh angefangen hat, richtig geraten oder kam das erst später?
Richtig geraten, kommt drauf an, wie früh früh ist.
Also vielleicht das früheste war die Liebe zu wissenschaftlichen Phänomenen,
angefangen mit irgendwelchen Magneten, Stecknadeln, Lupen, die man als Brenngläser verwendet,
um irgendwelche Papiere anzubrennen, so Sachen habe ich, glaube ich, schon als Vierjähriger, Fünfjähriger gemacht.
Und das ging dann halt immer mehr in das, was ich formales Denken nenne, rein.
Und also das allgemeine Problemlösen mit angeschaltetem Kopf.
Und ein Teil davon ist die Mathematik, ein anderer Teil davon ist die Informatik,
ein anderer Teil davon ist die E-Technik, die Physik und so weiter.
Und in dem Spielplatz habe ich mich im Prinzip als Kind bewegt und bin davon eigentlich bis jetzt noch nicht weggekommen.
Trotzdem gab es dann irgendwann, schlug das Pendel mehr in Richtung Mathematik aus?
Das Pendel schlug auf vielfältige Weise in Richtung Mathematik aus, aber nicht allein in Richtung Mathematik.
Als ich, nach dem Abi überlegt man dann irgendwann, was studierst du denn jetzt?
Und da stand bei mir die Wahl zwischen Physik, E-Technik, Informatik, Psychologie und Mathematik.
Und am Ende fiel die Wahl auf Mathematik, weil ich mir gesagt habe, Mathematik ist letztlich überall drin
und es ist die Grundlage von allem und wenn du irgendwann mal in den anderen Bereichen was machen willst,
dann ist die beste Grundausbildung die, dass du sagst, du machst Mathematik.
Und mittlerweile ist es so, ich stehe ständig mit einem Fuß in mindestens einem der anderen Gebiete nach wie vor noch drin
und habe aber auf dem Weg von damals bis jetzt aber auch schon das eine oder andere etwas fettere mathematische Problem geknackt.
Also wurde es dann ein Mathestudium?
Es wurde ein Mathestudium, Techno-Mathe, mit Nebenfach Informatik und E-Technik.
Also wie gesagt, das gehört alles irgendwo zusammen.
Wo?
Darmstadt, TU Darmstadt, TH damals noch.
80er Jahre.
Ja, da mussten sie, da gab es so einige Hochschulen, die später zu Universitäten wurden,
gerade über diese Linie, über die technische Informatik.
Naja, es ist letztlich eine Umbenennung stattgefunden, nachdem die Fachhochschulen sich sich dann irgendwann Hochschulen genannt haben,
dann wollten die technischen Hochschulen nicht mehr Hochschule heißen und ist alles okay.
TU Darmstadt, TH Darmstadt, klasse Adresse.
Ja auf jeden Fall ein sehr bekannter Name, gerade was so auch die Informatik betrifft.
Also viele Aktivitäten sicherlich so einer der, ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt führend sagen will, aber sagen wir mal zumindest,
so einer der Orte, die immer wieder fallen, wenn besondere Studien vorangetrieben werden und gute Forschung gemacht wird.
Gerade auch im Sicherheitsbereich ist, glaube ich, Darmstadt sehr bekannt.
Okay. Aber trotzdem führte der Weg dann irgendwann woanders hin, wohin ging es denn dann erst mal?
Nach der Zeit in Darmstadt war ich tatsächlich erst mal ein bisschen in der Industrie tätig
und habe für Firmen gearbeitet, oder für eine Firma gearbeitet, die NC-Steuerungsmaschinen programmiert hat.
Danach war ich eine Weile im Forschungszentrum der Telekom und danach ging es an die Universität zurück nach Berlin.
Da hatte ich ein Angebot von einem Kollegen, der gesagt hat, du bist blöd, wenn du nicht habilitierst.
Komm zu mir, ich habe eine Stelle, das war der Günther Ziegler, und ich habe die Zeit dort unglaublich genossen,
das war auch eine der Zeiten, in denen viele sehr spannende mathematische Ergebnisse gepurzelt sind.
Und da war ich bis, ich glaube, 97.
Danach dreieinhalb Jahre an der ETH Zürich und danach dann seit 2001 hier in München.
Die Vorlage muss ich nutzen, um noch mal hier auf Forschergeist 31 hinzuweisen,
da habe ich nämlich mit Günther Ziegler schon mal über das Abenteuer Mathematik gesprochen.
Und auch schon mal eine spezielle Perspektive eingenommen.
Heute werden wir, glaube ich, noch eine etwas andere Perspektive einnehmen,
aber auch da haben wir uns schon sehr viel über das Wesen von Mathematik als solchem unterhalten.
Dieser Weg von der Uni in die Industrie und wieder zurück, der interessiert mich.
Weil wir hatten das hier auch vor zwei Sendungen, als es um Computertomographie ging,
sagen wir mal, was eine Forschung ist, die sehr im industriellen Bereich stattfindet, weil sie sehr spezifisch ist,
weil sie sehr anwendungsorientiert ist.
Manche drängt es ja in diese konkreten Anwendungen, andere drängt es vielleicht eher in die Lehre oder eben auch in die Forschung.
Wenn man jetzt beides mal so mitgemacht hat, was ist der Reiz in dem einen Bereich, was ist der Reiz in dem anderen?
Also für mich ist der Reiz, auch da immer wieder Grenzgänger zu sein.
Also in dem Moment, wo man an Anwendungsproblemen arbeitet, sei es drum,
jetzt für die Firma zum Beispiel irgendwelche NC-Steuerungen, also numerisch controllte Fräsroboter damals zu machen,
wenn man das gut und richtig machen will, kommt man an der Mathematik nicht vorbei.
Und hinter dem, was ich vorhin so das formale Denken genannt habe.
Dann muss man ein Problem so weit durchdringen, dass danach auch eine bestmögliche Lösung irgendwo, wenn es geht, rauskommt.
Und das ist auch tatsächlich dann am Ende des Tages wirtschaftlich relevant.
Und ich habe in meinem Leben eigentlich so die Erfahrung gemacht, dass egal was man anfasst,
wenn es ein Problem zumindest im technischen, aber auch in vielen anderen Bereichen, ist,
dass man, wenn man es richtig machen will, um eine tiefe Durchdringung der dahinterliegenden Mathematik überhaupt nicht drum rum kommt.
Und umgekehrt, wenn man Mathematik kann und Mathematik macht, ich sage jetzt immer sehr pauschal Mathematik,
Mathematik ist eine extrem vielfältige Wissenschaft, also man kann eigentlich nicht von der einen Mathematik einfach so reden,
aber das lassen wir jetzt erst mal beiseite.
Aber wenn man diesen Werkzeugkasten hat, dann kann man auch unglaublich tolle Sachen damit machen
und ist dann natürlich aus der Theorie kommend dann wiederum auch sehr schnell bei interessanten Anwendungen,
wo die Mathematik einfach möglich macht, die ohne das gar nicht gingen.
Und dieses Wechselspiel finde ich mein Leben lang schon interessant.
Und natürlich noch den Bezug dann, diese Sachen auch tatsächlich in die Öffentlichkeit ein Stück reinzubringen,
damit, Sie fragen nach der Biografie, okay…
Jetzt hüpfe ich mal zurück in die Zeit irgendwo siebte, achte Klasse, da bin ich sehr gern in der Schule als Zauberer aufgetreten.
Und Mathematik gibt einem ein bisschen ähnliche Kräfte,
weil man kann damit manchmal Dinge machen, wo die Leute sagen, ach und wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Und wie passt das jetzt plötzlich zusammen?
Und dann kann man, wenn Mathematik und keine Zauberer hinten dran steckt, kann man dann sehr schön drüber reden und sagen,
ja jetzt fang doch mal an darüber nachzudenken, was siehst du denn hier, was hast du denn vor dir?
Warum führen denn dieses Effekte so schön zu dem, was du am Ende siehst?
Jetzt machen wir ein bisschen Visualisierung über Podcast, indem ich zumindest das Gefühl beschreibe,
das man hat, wenn man irgendwo was gut visualisiert bekommt.
Ja. Da kommen wir auf jeden Fall noch zu.
Das heißt, ich deute das jetzt mal als, das waren wertvolle Erfahrungen und schön zu sehen,
dass man sein konkretes mathematisches Wissen auch in einer Anwendung anbringt,
aber am Ende gab es dann doch mehr den Wunsch, das weiter zu vertiefen und da mehr Zugang zu einer Forschung zu haben,
Bereiche auszuloten, die noch nicht ausgelotet sind?
Ich liebe schwierige Probleme und die hat man natürlich in der mathematischen Grundlagenforschung an allen Ecken und Enden
und ich komme tatsächlich in meiner Forschungsrichtung eher aus einer Grundlagenecke,
wo es also jetzt nicht sofort darum geht, jetzt die und die konkrete Anwendung mit der Mathematik machen zu wollen.
Sondern, zum Beispiel als ich habilitiert habe, da ging es um theoretische Fragen von Vielflächen im vierdimensionalen Raum,
mit was man sich normalerweise gar nicht so sehr beschäftigen würde, hat aber durchaus auch wieder seine praktischen Aspekte.
Aber das war nicht der Reiz dabei, sondern der Reiz waren die schwierigen Probleme.
Und dann, ich unterrichte sehr gerne, ich erzähle gerne Dinge, die ich verstanden habe
und manchmal verstehe ich auch Dinge erst dadurch, dass ich darüber unterrichte.
Und dieses Zwischenspiel das hat mich eigentlich schon das ganze Leben über gereizt, macht mir großen Spaß.
Lehre ist mir eine ganz heilige und wichtige Aufgabe und von daher bin ich so in diesem Unibereich irgendwo fühle ich mich sehr gut aufgehoben.
Muss allerdings sagen, dass ich, und das ist vielleicht ein bisschen anders als bei manchen anderen Kollegen,
immer einen starken Drang auch nach außen raus habe, also aus den Dingen, die man jetzt macht,
dann wiederum etwas zu machen, was man eben auch anderen Leuten zeigen kann.
Und da bietet halt die Mathematik auch wieder einiges.
Und so führte das Ganze dann zu dieser Professur hier in München?
Genau.
Und worauf fokussiert sich jetzt dieser Lehrstuhl?
Der Lehrstuhl ist ein Lehrstuhl für Geometrie und Visualisierung.
Das heißt, in den beiden Wörtern stecken schon zwei Aspekte drin, die einfach wichtig sind.
Geometrie ist für uns wirklich auch ein ganzes Stück Grundlagenforschung,
mathematische Grundlagenforschung, aber eben die dann auch zu benutzen, um damit konkret Visualisierungen zu machen,
ist ein Teil der Forschung hier.
Das heißt, die Forschung hier am Lehrstuhl die geht von sogenannter geometrischer in Variantentheorie,
kombinatorische Geometrie, polytope Theorie, ist jetzt immer hinten dran das Wort Theorie
und das heißt auch schon, das ist eher so im Grundlagenaspekt verankert.
Bis aber eben dazu hin, dass es eine der wichtigen Aufgaben hier ist, mathematische Grundlagen zu schaffen,
die dann wiederum die softwaregestützte Umsetzung von Geometrie und Mathematik auf dem Computer überhaupt erst ermöglichen.
Und da stellt man dann, ich habe vorhin schon mal gesagt, wenn man eine Sache richtig machen will,
braucht man jede Menge Mathematik dazu und auch da stellt sich raus, wenn man Dinge gut und korrekt visualisieren möchte,
in die Anschauung reinbringen möchte, dann ist auf dem Weg dahin tatsächlich wiederum viel Mathematik zu betreiben.
Das heißt, was wir hier auch viel machen, sind einfach wirklich mathematische Grundlagen von interaktiven Visualisierungen,
wobei ein Schwerpunkt hier bei uns am Lehrstuhl wirklich auf dem Interaktionsaspekt liegt,
also es geht uns weniger darum, Filmsequenzen zu produzieren, als darum, Werkzeuge zu produzieren,
mit denen man interaktive Spielszenarien letztlich bauen kann.
Mit denen man mathematische Effekte erklären kann, indem die Leute mit diesen Produkten am Ende in Interaktion treten mit Maus und Finger und am Bildschirm.
Und letztlich selbst ein Stück zum Forscher werden als ein Konzept.
Also wir haben ja auch viele Zusammenarbeiten mit der TUM School of Education.
Ein Konzept, das wir an der Stelle immer wieder haben, sind sogenannte Mikrolaboratorien.
Das sind kleine abgezirkelte interaktive Spielfelder, in denen der Benutzer am Ende selbst zum Forscher werden kann.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel Dinge über Molekülbildung von geladenen Teilchen,
wo man mit einem Schieberegler einstellen kann, welche Ladung haben die denn jetzt,
welchen Nahwirkungsabstoßungsradius haben die und dann plötzlich Effekte sieht und erlebt,
die ansonsten auf molekularer Ebene stattfinden und darüber bekommt man ein viel besseres Verständnis dafür,
wie sind dann letztlich hinten dran die Wirkmechanismen.
Und wie gesagt, um das zu machen, braucht es dann wieder einen Haufen mathematische Theorie
und die machen wir hier am Lehrstuhl.
So lange Antwort auf kurze Frage.
Naja gut, aber das wirkt ja dann auch nicht nur in die Informatik rein, wenn Software beteiligt ist,
sondern jetzt auch in die Chemie und die Physik und im Prinzip ja eigentlich auch in alle Felder.
Und das ist eigentlich so das Ding, Mathematik, finde ich, hat so eine Sonderrolle in den Wissenschaften,
weil es einfach so eine Schlüsselwissenschaft ist, die ja irgendwo in allem drin steckt.
Also mir würde jetzt zumindest kaum etwas einfallen, man könnte natürlich jetzt drüber diskutieren,
inwiefern die Geisteswissenschaft von der Mathematik beseelt oder bevölkert ist,
aber sie kann sich zumindest über Mathematik, glaube ich, auch viel Gedanken darüber machen,
was die Mathematik quasi zu erklären in der Lage ist und was vielleicht auch nicht.
Was ist denn so aus Ihrer Perspektive dieser Stellenwert?
Ist das so, wie ich das beschrieben habe, was kann man da noch zu sagen
und welchen Stellenwert hat Mathe auch in der Gesellschaft als solche aus Ihrer Sicht?
Oh vielfältige Frage.
Also das eine habe ich vorhin schon gesagt bei meiner Studienwahl.
Ich habe Mathe studiert, weil es eben überall drinsteckt.
Und in dem Moment, wo man Wissenschaft betreibt im Sinne von, ich schränke jetzt zunächst mal auf Naturwissenschaften ein,
kommt man um die Mathematik als Grundlage gar nicht drumrum.
Theoretische Informatik ist letztlich Mathematik und Mathematik ist letztlich die Grundlage von allen Naturwissenschaften.
Das Buch der Natur ist in den Sprachen der Mathematik geschrieben.
Aber auch in dem Moment, Sie haben eben die Geisteswissenschaften angesprochen,
da ist es tatsächlich so, dass viele Bereiche der Geisteswissenschaften auch von Mathematik durchdrungen sind.
Nehmen Sie die Linguistik zum Beispiel her, da geht es ganz viel um logischen Aufbau von Sprache.
Viele Linguisten sind auf der Schnittstelle auch zur Mathematik anzuordnen.
Und gerade in unserer heutigen Zeit, wo zum Beispiel Computer Sprache erkennen sollen, Sprache reproduzieren sollen,
wird so ein Teil zum Beispiel auch direkt von Mathematik durchdrungen.
Ich würde sogar sagen, die Linguistik war die Geburtsstunde der Informatik, weil so in den 50er Jahren…
In gewissem Sinne ja klar.
… waren das ja eigentlich so die Kernzellen.
Klar Chomsky und so weiter, ist zumindest ein wichtiger Bereich und nicht umsonst heißt es ja in der Informatik auch Programmiersprache.
Das ist ja schon das Konzept einer Syntaxgrammatik und so weiter dahinter.
Sie haben eben noch gefragt, der Stellenwert der Mathematik in der Gesellschaft.
Ich würde sagen, sie wird nach wie vor an vielen vielen Punkten massiv unterschätzt
und viele Teile der Bevölkerung unterschätzen aber auch sich selbst massiv,
weil sie einfach viel mehr Mathematik können als sie sich zutrauen.
Und eigentlich auch in ganz vielen Zusammenhängen ständig irgendwo formal Mathematik betreiben,
ohne zu sagen, das ist jetzt Mathematik.
Also nehmen Sie die ganzen Sudoku-Puzzler und ähnliches, die haben riesigen Spaß am Sudoku und sagen,
nein, aber lass mich bitte mit Mathematik in Ruhe und das ist so ein bisschen auch ein Bewusstseinsprozess,
den ich auf Seiten der Wissenschaft in der Schuld sehe, den Leuten überhaupt zu zeigen,
wo benutzt du denn überhaupt alles Mathematik.
Oder wenn wir jetzt hier über das Mischpult reden…
Ist Sudoku nicht mehr Informatik?
Naja, Sudoku ist ein Problem, okay.
Jetzt kommen wir in dieses Unterteilen der einzelnen Bereiche.
Und ich habe ganz bewusst vorhin den Begriff formal Reasoning, formales Denken mit reingebracht,
weil ich glaube, das ist etwas, woran es uns in vielen Bereichen in unserer Gesellschaft immer noch viel zu sehr fehlt,
dass Leute sich nicht trauen, auch mal formal über Dinge nachzudenken.
Und das macht man in der Mathematik, in der Physik, in der Informatik, in der E-Technik.
Und diesen Zugang bewusst zu wählen in einem Gemisch aus Synthese und Analyse,
ein Problem erst mal auseinanderzunehmen, um danach wieder zusammenzusetzen, um zu einer Lösung zu kommen,
das ist etwas, was letztlich eine bewusste Entscheidung dafür voraussetzt.
Und Thema Kreativität und Kunst und Musik und ähnliches, nehmen Sie aktuelle Audioproduktionen von irgendwelchen Popsongs oder ähnliches,
dahinter steckt, so wie das heute passiert, ohne dass es den Leuten manchmal bewusst ist, jede Menge formal Reasoning
und damit auch wieder jede Menge mathematisches Denken.
Ich meine, das lässt sich ja nicht wegdiskutieren, dass es diese Zurückhaltung gibt gegenüber.
Das fängt bei manchen schon in der Schule an.
Aber generell ist Mathematik schon, da scheiden sich sozusagen die Geister ab dem Moment,
wo das erste Mal so eine komplexe Formel vor einem steht.
Manche wollen sich daran nicht beteiligen.
Aber auch so dieses einfache, ich sage mal diese Sudoku-Mathematik, die jedem ja irgendwie noch liegt
und die vielleicht eben auch so ein bisschen was von, ich programmiere jetzt hier mal einen Algorithmus,
um irgendwie die richtige Zahl herauszufinden, damit was zu tun hat,
auch da gibt es ja eine Zurückhaltung und ich frage mich halt immer, was eigentlich der Grund dafür ist.
Ist es die pure Komplexität, der sich Leute nicht gewachsen sehen
oder ist es auch so ein bisschen die Angst vor so einer formalen klaren digitalen Wahrheit,
die man dann irgendwie erreicht oder nicht erreicht, dass man irgendwie so die Dinge nicht offen lassen sein kann?
Auch hier Antwort ist vielfältig und vieles geht, glaube ich, auf die persönliche Entwicklungsgeschichte von verschiedenen Leuten einfach zurück.
Also soweit ich weiß gibt es Studien, die sagen, bei vielen Personen ging der Mathematikvorhang zu Zeiten der Grundschule zu.
Und das mag daran liegen, dass man sehr schnell in der Grundschule damit konfrontiert wird,
Mathematik ist das, wo es am Ende immer nur eine richtige Lösung gibt
und auch vielleicht nur einen richtigen Rechenweg und das ist aber Mathematik nicht.
Also wir haben hier am Campus unsere Mathematikausstellung, in der wir Kinder beginnend ab Vorschulalter,
Grundschule bis Mittelstufe und so weiter mit drin haben.
Und tatsächlich das forschende Herangehen, wie wir es teilweise bei Kindern bis zur ungefähr zweiten Klasse beobachten,
ist dem eines echten mathematischen Grundlagenforschers viel ähnlicher als das,
was wir häufig beobachten, was man dann so zehnte, elfte, zwölfte Klasse bekommt,
wo man drauf gestreamlined wurde, okay Mathematik ist jetzt das, wo ich rechnen muss
und das, wo ich jetzt erst mal aus einer Textaufgabe rausfiltern muss, was ist denn da jetzt der mathematische Gehalt
und das in eine Formel packen und dann muss ich auf diese Formel ein Verfahren anwenden,
das ich vorher irgendwo vielleicht auswendig gelernt habe und da macht natürlich Mathematik nicht mehr so schrecklich viel Spaß
und da ist man natürlich auch sehr schnell an der Stelle, wo Dinge schnell fehlerhaft werden können,
weil einfach die Pfade so eng gesteckt sind.
Und auf der Uni wird das tatsächlich dann wieder, je weiter man im Studium fortschreitet,
wieder weiter und weiter dieser Blickwinkel, so dass man am Ende, wenn man ein mathematisches Forscherleben führt,
tatsächlich eine komplette Methodenoffenheit hat.
Und genau diese Erfahrung, glaube ich, dass Mathematik häufig etwas, was von außen bewertet wird,
dass man erst mal nicht so kann und man sehr viel Frustration einstecken muss,
das ist was, was vielen Leuten auf dem Weg, ich formuliere es jetzt mal vorsichtig,
zumindest eine gewisse Berührungsangst zu Mathematik und formalem Denken macht.
Ich habe kein Patentrezept, wie man dagegen wirkt, aber ich glaube, dass man viel viel viel positiver mit Mathematik in der Gesellschaft umgehen könnte.
Ich hatte einmal, ich muss noch eine Geschichte ganz kurz loswerden.
Ich hatte einmal eine Schlüsselerfahrung, da war ich auf einem Lehrerkongress in Berlin,
stand am Gendarmenmarkt, habe mir ein Musiker, der da mit der Gitarre spielte, angehört
und da kam eine Frau dazu geradelt, hat sich später als die Freundin von dem Gitarrenspieler rausgestellt
und wir kamen ins Gespräch und sie fragte, ja und was machst denn du da?
Und ich meinte, ich bin jetzt hier auf einem Lehrerkongress und es geht um Mathematik.
Und sie kam irgendwo aus Polen oder Ungarn und sagte sofort, ach wie toll,
Mathematik das ist ja so ein unglaublich spannendes Feld, hätte ich gerne viel mehr von gemacht.
Also ich glaube, es gibt andere, gerade zum Beispiel in Ungarn, anderen kulturellen Umgang,
wie man Mathematik als ein spannendes und offenes Feld, indem man einfach seinen Werkzeugkasten beherrschen muss
und in dem es sich aber auch lohnt, den Werkzeugkasten zu beherrschen.
Klingt jetzt so ein bisschen so, als ob dann in der dritten Schulklasse irgendwo ein Fehler gemacht wird, wie das weiter verfolgt wird.
Lässt sich da irgendwo der Finger drauflegen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich definiere mich ganz bewusst nicht als Didaktiker.
Ich arbeite zwar viel mit Didaktikern zusammen, das ist deren Aufgabe, diese Frage letztlich zu klären.
Es ist ein Stück eine empirische Beobachtung und ich kann sagen, es gibt zumindest auch Studien, die in die Richtung zeigen.
Aber wo jetzt genau an der Stelle der Knackpunkt ist, ist schwierig zu sagen.
Was ich halt wichtig finde, ist, man sollte vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtiger mit dem Thema richtig oder falsch umgehen.
Noch eine andere Geschichte, meine Tochter in der zweiten Klasse, sie sollten sich Aufgaben ausdenken
und sie hatten gerade Subtraktion gemacht und sie fing dann an, hatte so was wie
Ich habe mich natürlich berufen gefühlt, ihr einen wunderbaren Vortrag über die 0 und dann über negative Zahlen in der zweiten Klasse zu halten,
was sie auch vollständig verstanden hat und sie schrieb dann also voll Stolz hin, 5-6=-1
und die Lehrerin setzte ein fettes F dahinter, weil sie das zu dem Zeitpunkt einfach noch nicht wissen durften.
Wurde nicht vermittelt ist …
Wurde nicht vermittelt, muss so falsch sein.
Und das ist jetzt natürlich anekdotische Evidenz, wie wir das immer so schön nennen,
aber ich glaube, da lässt sich vieles besser machen und auf der anderen Seite muss dann der Lehrer
oder die Lehrerin auch lernen, mehr und mehr in eine Rolle von einem Moderator reingehen zu können,
der mit den ganzen offenen Fragen, die einfach sehr schnell entstehen, wenn man über Mathematik diskutiert,
irgendwo auch umgehen kann und auch zugeben können muss, ja tut mir leid, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Kann sein, dass ich über Nachdenken darauf komme, kann sein, dass wir einen Experten fragen müssen.
Weil in der Mathematik ist es so, dass jenseits der Pfade, die man so typischerweise in der Schule geht,
auch sehr schnell Bereiche kommen, in denen offene mathematische Probleme liegen.
Und das ist gleichzeitig der Reiz und gleichzeitig auch die große Schwierigkeit in der Mathematik.
Und unseren Studenten im ersten Semester predigen wir immer, das wichtigste, was sie brauchen, ist Frustrationstoleranz.
Weil es gibt nichts frustrierenderes als Mathematik, aber auch nichts schöneres,
wenn man durch irgendetwas in der Mathematik durchgekommen ist und am Ende so einen Erweckermoment hat
und sich der Knoten im Kopf aufgelöst hat.
Was frustriert Sie denn, also was ist denn so ein frustrierendes Problem?
Dauernd.
Also ich hüpfe jetzt gerade mal zu Zeiten meiner Habil zurück.
Da hatte ich mir ein relativ sehr schwieriges Problem vorgenommen und ich habe ein halbes Jahr nur eine Sackgasse nach der anderen abgegrast.
Und da nicht irgendwann zu sagen, nein ich lasse das Problem jetzt Problem sein und habe damit nichts zu tun,
das erfordert schon so einen gewissen Biss und Frustrationstoleranz.
Gerade wenn man in der Forschungsmathematik ist, ist es so, dass einfach die Wege, die am Ende zum Ziel führen,
halt in aller Regel kein bisschen vorgezeichnet sind und von daher ist Mathematik halt auch eine extrem kreative Wissenschaft
und tatsächlich Thema Kreativität für dieses Problem, um das es da bei der Habil ging,
die Idee dazu war irgendwo an dem Tag, also die Idee für die letztliche Lösung war an dem Tag, an dem meine Tochter geboren wurde
und ich mit komplett anderen Sachen im Kopf eigentlich beschäftigt war,
da hat sich dann irgendwo in einer Ecke hinten im Kopf geregt, Mensch mach das mit dem Problem doch so,
kümmere dich jetzt nicht drum, aber mache das so und du kommst am Ende durch.
Und dazu waren dann aber auch die ganzen Sackgassen, die vorher abgegrast wurden, die waren essentiell wichtig,
weil ich wusste, was alles nicht geht.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass viele Leute so ein Problem haben, sich Kreativität im Zusammenhang mit Mathematik vorzustellen.
Es gibt nichts kreativeres.
Ja, das mag sein, aber sich das vorzustellen.
Also ein Problem lösen, wo kommt das Problem her, was hat denn dieses Problem, über das Sie gerade gesprochen haben,
denn so schwierig gemacht und was war denn der kreative Kniff, der letzten Endes zu einer Lösung geführt hat?
Okay, jetzt werden wir echt mathematisch.
Ja, muss ja auch mal sein.
Wir reden über Vielflächen, Mathematiker nennen das ein Polytop.
Und Vielflächen sind Objekte, die aus geraden Flächen als Begrenzung existieren, zum Beispiel ein Würfel.
Und so ein Würfel, der hat zwei Ebenen, auf denen er lebt.
Also wir haben einerseits den Würfel, wie er jetzt zum Beispiel vor uns liegt, mit konkreten Koordinaten,
die Ecken haben bestimmte Koordinaten und andererseits hat der aber auch eine kombinatorische Struktur.
Welche Ecke liegt auf welcher Seitenfläche.
Ich könnte mir zum Beispiel für einen Würfel eine Liste machen, ein Würfel hat sechs Seiten,
weiß man von einem normalen Würfel und hat acht Ecken
und dann könnte ich mir eine Liste machen, wo ich mir die Ecken durchnummeriere,
diese Ecke liegt auf dieser Seite, diese liegt auf dieser Seite und so weiter.
Jetzt gebe ich Ihnen vielleicht diese Liste, die ich mir angefertigt habe und frage Sie,
können Sie mir so was bauen?
Und dann stellt sich raus, gucken Sie einmal drauf und denken, ach klasse, ist ein Würfel.
Jetzt gebe ich Ihnen eine kompliziertere Liste und frage Sie, können Sie das bauen?
Und dann kommen Sie schon ins Knobeln rein.
Und tatsächlich für drei Dimensionen war diese Übergangsfrage, wie kommt man von solchen Listen zu konkreten Realisationen,
die ist seit 1922 gelöst durch einen klassischen Satz, den Satz von Steinitz.
Aber für vierdimensionale Polytope war das seit praktisch damals, seit 70 Jahren offen.
Wie schwierig wird das, wie kann man überhaupt zu Lösungen kommen,
wie sehen die Räume der Lösungen aus und und und.
Und da haben sich einige dran versucht, das gescheit hinzukriegen.
Und das ist halt ein sehr hartnäckiges Problem, weil man erstens in vier Dimensionen jetzt nicht so unbedingt die beste Intuition hat.
Da muss man sich erst einen Werkzeugkasten zusammenbauen, mit dem man überhaupt erst mal in vier Dimensionen sich Dinge vorstellen kann
und für solche Probleme ist die Vorstellung was wichtiges.
Und tatsächlich dieses Problem hat sich dann dadurch gelöst, ich habe vorhin gesagt, ich habe mich als Kind auch mit E-Technik beschäftigt.
Und in E-Technik setzt man ja verschiedene Bauteile zusammen, um am Ende was daraus zu machen.
Zum Beispiel ein Radio der ein iPhone letztlich auch oder Handy, um es hier werbungsneutral zu sagen.
Und so was ähnliches passierte bei dem Problem.
Es ging darum, sich ein Werkzeugkasten an kleinen Bausteinen zusammenzulegen,
aus denen man eine unglaubliche Komplexität zusammenbauen konnte,
um zu zeigen, dass dieses Problem, dass man da im vierdimensionalen sich dann definiert, beweisbar schwierig ist.
Das fällt dann in die Klasse der mindestens NP-schweren Probleme.
Und da ging es dann darum, einerseits Bausteine zu definieren, sich zusammen auszudenken,
die bestimmte kleine Aufgaben machen und andererseits einen Mechanismus zu finden,
wie man diese Bausteine zusammensetzen kann.
Und dieser Mechanismus hat sich als schwierig herausgestellt und da war dann irgendwann die Schlüsselidee,
man muss die Verklebeflächen irgendwo geschickt wählen.
Will ich jetzt gar nicht genau erklären, wie man sie wählen muss, aber da kommt man dann,
wenn man die Idee hat und die Bausteine hat, dann kommt man auf einmal damit durch.
Klingt jetzt alles schrecklich abstrakt, befürchte ich, macht aber wahnsinnig Spaß.
Ist ein wunderschönes Knobelspiel, mit dem man sich problemlos ein halbes Jahr lang beschäftigen kann.
Aber ich meine, es führt ja in gewisser Hinsicht direkt zu diesem Lehrstuhl.
Weil ein Problem lösen heißt ja, es sich vorstellen zu können und das bedeutet eben,
wir wollen es vor unserem geistigen Auge in irgendeiner Form „sehen“.
Ich muss ein bisschen widersprechen.
Für mich ist das so, ist aber nicht für jeden Mathematiker zwangsläufig so.
Also es gibt durchaus Mathematiker, die sehr stark rein auf der formalisierten Ebene über ein Problem nachdenken können.
Wo das Thema, was man sich am Ende vorstellen kann, eher von der Logik noch mit abgelöst wird.
Und für die Mathematik auch ein zu weiten Teilen formaler Prozess ist.
Und dann gibt es Leute, die sich, wenn sie irgendwas verstehen wollen, sich das immer vorstellen müssen,
zu denen gehöre ich und alle Schattierungen irgendwo zwischendrin und in beide Richtungen natürlich auch noch Extreme,
die noch über mich oder andere Kollegen dann jeweils hinausgehen, das ist ein Spektrum, von dem wir da reden.
Und das ist übrigens auch in der Lehre sehr wichtig, dass man versucht,
in seiner Lehre die verschiedenen Typen von Mathematikern, die man jetzt vor sich hat, auch anzusprechen.
Und ich will das jetzt nicht irgendwo plump reduzieren auf visuelle Typen, auditive Typen und solche, die nur mit Sprache können,
sondern es ist eher so die Frage, ob man ein Problem alleine von der formalen Seite
oder allein von einer diagrammatischen Seite, wo es mehr um vorstellen geht, angeht
oder welche Schattierung man dazwischen wählt.
Und die Kunst dann am Ende, wenn man guter Mathematiker ist, besteht darin, die beiden Seiten gut miteinander zu verknüpfen.
Gibt es denn auch so Leute, die so, es gibt ja dieses Phänomen der Synästhesie,
dass man Zahlen oder Buchstaben oder was auch immer über Wärme, Farben oder so etwas wahrnimmt,
haben Sie bei sich so was ähnliches festgestellt, dass die Mathematik gleich so auf eine Art und Weise in einen hineinläuft,
dass es automatisch irgendetwas auslöst?
Also sagen wir es mal so, für mich ist Mathematik auch sehr stark mit Gefühlen, Gespür eher verbunden.
Also jetzt nicht im Sinne von Sinneseindrücken, dass ich sage, das Theorem fühlt sich jetzt rot an und das andere blau,
so was habe ich nicht, das klingt nach Beethoven und das klingt nach Cold Train, wobei ein bisschen vielleicht schon.
Aber was ich tatsächlich für mich habe ist so ein Gespür, wann Sachen eher richtig oder eher falsch sind.
Und ich führe das darauf zurück, das ist jetzt auch wieder so eine ganz absurde autobiografische Geschichte,
ich war in der Schule schrecklich in Kopfrechnen, ich konnte das nicht.
Also ich war immer langsam und ich war auch selten unbedingt sofort richtig
und ich habe mir dann irgendwann angewöhnt, jede Aufgabe auf mindestens drei verschiedene Arten im Kopf zu rechnen
und per Mehrheitsentscheid dann zu sagen, okay, 3+7 muss dann wohl eher 10 sein als 11,
weil zweimal gerechnet kommt 10 raus und einmal kam 11 raus.
Was dabei aber entstanden ist, es hat sich im Kopf bei mir ein Netzwerk gebildet aus verschiedenen Wegen an dasselbe Problem ranzugehen
und dieses Netz, das glaube ich, das gibt es immer noch und das sagt einem dann,
okay, das hier, das riecht jetzt ein bisschen richtig und das hier, das riecht jetzt ein bisschen falsch.
So dass man Sackgassen, von denen ich vorhin gesprochen habe, vielleicht ein Stück früher abschneiden kann.
Dass man so Bewertungspfade quasi entwickelt und sagt so, ja das fühlt sich näher und damit vielleicht richtiger an.
An der Wahrheit an.
Wahrheit ist auch meistens ein bisschen schön.
Zumindest ein bisschen.
Also wenn ich irgendein mathematisches Problem angehe und jetzt mich all zu sehr in ganz wilden Formeln vergaloppiere,
und der Überzeugung bin, nein ich brauche diese Formeln nicht, das Problem hat einen anderen Charakter,
dann höre ich auf zu rechnen und suche nach einem anderen Ansatz, weil ich einfach denke,
durch rechnen alleine kommst du an der Stelle nicht weiter.
Wahrheit ist ein bisschen schön.
Schönheit ist manchmal auch ein bisschen wahr.
Ja. Ohne mich zu sehr damit beschäftigt zu haben, aber es gibt, glaube ich, in der Astronomie
und damit auch in der Astrophysik so ein bisschen auch die Frage immer dieser Vorstellung des Universums,
was ja auch sehr schwierig ist zu visualisieren, weil es halt auf der einen Seite ja einerseits vor allem mathematisch beschrieben ist,
über Einstein und auch durch die Quantenmechanik und die wollen dann irgendwie auch nicht so richtig zusammen
und das ist schon mal so ein Bruch, aber generell ist ja auch so dieses Nachdenken über das größte, weiteste und wichtigste
und alles vielleicht auch in irgendeiner Form vereinigende, da braucht man ja dann eben auch so ein Gespür
und ich habe so wahrgenommen, dass es auch dort auf der einen Seite immer so dieses klassische,
die Wahrheit kündigt sich durch Schönheit an, gibt auf der einen Seite,
aber auch durchaus eine andere Fraktion sagt, nein das ist bestimmt eine Sackgasse,
vielleicht ist das auch alles viel komplizierter, um hier irgendwie zum Ziel zu kommen.
Das ist ja auch ein ziemlicher Kriegsschauplatz, wie nehmen Sie das wahr?
Also ich bin eher auf der Schönheitsseite an der Stelle.
Ja okay, die Vermutung hatte ich schon.
Also ich sehe es so, dass unser Universum eine Kaskade von emergenten Prozessen ist,
also wo sich praktisch ein Prozess aus dem jeweils darunter liegenden ergibt.
Also nehmen wir unsere Wetterphänomene, da gibt es irgendwo unten drunten die Fluiddynamik und Thermodynamik,
die beschreibt wie der Wind geht und dann noch eine Ebene drunter landet man dann irgendwo bei der statistischen Kinematik,
und da muss man sich drüber Gedanken machen, wie sind eigentlich die Atome aufgebaut, die das machen
und dann kommt man noch weiter runter irgendwann auf die Quarks und je kleiner die Teilchen werden,
umso grundlegender und einfacher werden die Zusammenhänge dabei auch, ich hoffe,
dass ich jetzt keinen physikalischen totalen Blödsinn erzähle, aber zumindest nehme ich es so wahr,
dass also unser Elementarteilchenzoo am Ende doch deutlich geordneter zu sein scheint
als jetzt zum Beispiel das stürmische Wetter, von dem wir heute nicht wissen, ob morgen die Sonne scheint oder nicht.
Aber trotzdem diese Zusammenhänge von dem ganz unten, ich nenne jetzt mal die kleinen Sachen eher unten
und die großen Sachen eher oben, doch zwischendrin darauf beruhen, dass man praktisch Dinge zusammensetzt
und komplexere Dinge daraus entstehen.
Und von daher habe ich eigentlich immer noch die Hoffnung, dass wenn man ganz ganz ganz weit runter geht,
dass da dann die Sachen vielleicht auch so richtig überraschend einfach sind.
Es am Ende vielleicht nur zwei, drei Regeln gibt, aus denen sich alles am Ende ergibt.
Die aber so kräftig sind und das sind auch wieder Teile der Mathematik,
die sich genau damit beschäftigen, was sind denn zum Beispiel einfache Regeln,
die komplexes Verhalten erzeugen können?
Das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Teil, den wir in der Visualisierung ganz häufig machen,
dass wir gezielt über Themen reden, wie man aus einfachen Regeln komplexes Verhalten, komplexe Formen oder ähnliches erzeugen kann,
Pflanzenwachstum ist ein interessantes Beispiel dafür, Fischschwärme sind ein interessantes Beispiel.
Also in unserer Software kann ich in acht Zeilen einen realistisch aussehenden Fischschwarm zusammenprogrammieren,
aus dem dann plötzlich aus den einfachen Regeln durch emergente Prozesse scheinbar komplexes Verhalten rauskommt.
Jetzt waren wir quasi beim Thema dieses Lehrstuhls, der Bedeutung auch der Visualisierung.
Ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen so Escher-Bilder gerade im Kopf, ja, von Maurits Escher,
wo ja eine Form in das andere übergebt, aber er es auf der anderen Seite auch geschafft hat,
das Paradoxe in irgendeiner Form zu visualisieren.
Dass, wenn man es sich anschaut, so treppauf, treppab auf einmal die Dinge im Kopf dann auch gar nicht wieder zusammenbekommt.
Welche Bedeutung hat diese Visualisierung für die Mathematik und was ist hier so der Ansatz, was ist auch der Bedarf?
Okay, Sie sprechen jetzt den Kern hier meines Lehrstuhls letztlich an und ich könnte Ihnen jetzt darüber ungefähr drei Wochen einen Vortrag halten.
Ich versuche, mich jetzt trotzdem ein bisschen kurz zu fassen.
Na dann mal los.
Dazu müssen wir überhaupt erst mal sehen, was heißt überhaupt Visualisierung?
Visualisierung da steckt ja irgendwo visuell, das Optische irgendwo mit drin
und das heißt, sichtbar machen von irgendwas.
Jetzt die nächste Frage, was will man eigentlich sichtbar machen?
Und eine Variante, mit der man viel zu tun hat, wenn man das Wort Visualisierung hört,
ist zum Beispiel Datenvisualisierung und damit haben wir jetzt hier am Lehrstuhl so gut wie gar nichts am Hut,
weil wir wollen Strukturen visualisieren, Zusammenhänge visualisieren.
Und wir haben jetzt schon einiges darüber gehört, dass Mathematik zuweilen eine recht abstrakte Wissenschaft ist.
Und dass trotzdem bei den Leuten, die Mathematik betreiben, dazu Bilder im Kopf sind.
Und unsere Aufgabe ist dann zum Beispiel, diese Bilder, die meistens nur im Kopf sind,
und die teilweise auch sehr schwer zu visualisieren sind, aus dem Kopf raus auf den Computerbildschirm zu bringen.
Und an der Stelle ein Schwerpunkt, den wir hier am Lehrstuhl haben, ist die interaktive Visualisierung.
Das heißt, es soll eben nicht nur ein Bild oder ein Film geschaffen werden,
sondern ein komplexes Interaktionsszenario, mit dem praktisch der Benutzer davon selbst zum Forscher wird
in diesem kleinen Bereich, also wir nennen das dann häufig ein Mikrolaboratorium.
Und wie gesagt, um das zu machen, ist viel Mathematik notwendig und dann sehen wir jetzt eine Spielart der Visualisierung,
ist das Visualisieren von Mathematik selbst.
Also Mathematik ist etwas, ich habe vorher gesagt, ich bin abgeschreckt, wenn ich eine Formel sehe
und das schreckt viele Leute ab, machen wir doch mal klar, was eigentlich hinter der Formel steckt.
Und die meisten Formeln lassen sich auch tatsächlich sehr gut in Bilder/Filme/Animationen/interaktive Animationen entsprechend umsetzen.
Das ist eine Spielart.
Eine andere Spielart ist, Visualisierung von zum Beispiel emergenten Prozessen,
das was ich eben mit dem Fischschwarm angesprochen habe.
Da geht es jetzt nicht per se darum, eine abstrakte Struktur irgendwo darzustellen,
sondern etwas was man zum Beispiel in der Natur als Wirkmechanismus erkannt hat,
wie Moleküle zusammenfinden, wie eine Pflanze wächst, wie eben der Fischschwarm,
der schon fast metaphorisch hier geworden ist, wie der letztlich sich selbst kontrolliert
und an der Stelle finde ich immer eine Klarheit etwas sehr wichtiges.
Also es geht nicht darum, also das wäre dann Hollywood, die dann eben dann versuchen,
einen möglichst realistischen Filmschwarm für irgendeinen Ocean-Thriller oder sonst was zusammenzubauen.
Um was es bei uns geht ist nicht, einen möglichst realistischen Fischschwarm zu bauen,
sondern einen Fischschwarm zusammen mit seinen Wirkmechanismen so dazustellen,
dass man versteht, was da passiert und eben dann darüber ins Nachdenken kommen kann.
Lässt sich denn ein Fischschwarm jetzt rein mathematisch beschreiben, ohne Erkenntnisse aus der Biologie,
der Meeresbiologie oder so zu haben?
Sicherlich nicht im letzten Detail, aber in einigen strukturellen Zusammenhängen durchaus schon.
Also so ein Fisch ist ja am Ende ein relativ, ja, Wesen mit einem einigermaßen beschränkten Horizont.
Also der weiß ja, wenn er jetzt irgendwo schwimmt, nicht unbedingt, was der Fisch ein paar Meter weit weg
am anderen Ende des Fischschwarms macht, trotzdem gibt es Regeln, die zum Beispiel die Kohärenz von so einem Schwarm bedingen
und das sind eigentlich drei einfache Regeln.
Also erste Regel, krach nicht in deinen Nachbarn rein, also wenn du irgendwo direkt auf einen Nachbarn zuschwimmst,
weiche halt doch irgendwie aus.
Zweite Regel, guck dich um und schau, wo sind deine Nachbarfische und versuche auch da hinzuschwimmen.
Dritte Regel, guck dich um und schau, in welche Richtung schwimmen deine Nachbarn und versuche dich ähnlich zu verhalten.
Wenn man nur die drei Regeln nimmt und das in den Computer zum Beispiel reinprogrammiert,
dann entsteht auf einmal ein sehr realistisch aussehender Fischschwarm.
Und damit kann man auch andere, also Thema Soziologie, also in unserer Schwarmsimulation kann man mit Parametern spielen
und da gibt es zum Beispiel auch die Möglichkeit zu sagen, ich sehe nur zwei Nachbarn.
Und dann versuchen sich eigentlich immer zwei Fische zu finden und so ein kleines Pärchen zu bilden.
Und dann gibt es aber manchmal den einsamen Fisch, der dem Pärchen hinterher jagt, um selbst Anschluss zu finden.
Und das simuliert dann auch das, was manchmal auf einer Party passiert,
wenn sich die Pärchen gefunden haben und Leute, die noch nicht Anschluss gefunden haben, dann den Pärchen hinterher laufen.
Also von daher, Soziologie gibt da natürlich gezielter oder tiefer Auskunft,
Aber grundlegende Prinzipien kann man schon mal ein bisschen mit Mathematik an der Stelle versuchen zu verstehen.
Bei dem Fischschwarm, ich meine, woher weiß man denn jetzt, was die Wahrheit ist?
Wahrheit.
Ich meine, klar, man kann jetzt die…
Was ist schon wahr, meine Güte.
Was ist schon wahr, das müssen wir jetzt final klären.
Nein, schaffen wir nicht.
Natürlich schaffen wir das nicht, nur man kann jetzt Regeln aufstellen, man kann die sich ja,
die stehen ja nirgendwo fest, sondern das sind ja jetzt auch nur welche, die man sich im Prinzip ausgedacht hat,
mit denen man das mal ausprobiert und dann sieht man so, aha okay, damit komme ich jetzt irgendwie so und so weit
und das sieht schon mal aus wie ein Fischschwarm.
Nur stößt es ja dann auch irgendwann an so eine Grenze, wo es dann vielleicht nicht mehr aussieht wie ein Fischschwarm so.
Natürlich, klar.
Das ist ja dann quasi auch so der Test für eine solche Visualisierung, inwiefern sie dann jetzt eben der gewünschten Wahrheit
oder dem gewünschten Wahrheitsgehalt, wie sehr sie dem entgegenkommt.
Es gibt im Bereich der Computeranimation diesen schönen Begriff des uncanny valley.
Dass, wenn man, auch wenn es jetzt erst mal ein ganz anderer Bereich ist, man visualisiert Menschen mit dem Computer,
schafft es eben auch bis zu einem bestimmten Bereich ranzukommen, aber irgendwo so kurz vorher endet es,
irgendwo bricht das zusammen.
So und auch die künstliche Intelligenz Forschung hat ja genau dieses selbe Problem,
man ist mit all diesen Ansätzen sehr weit gekommen und dann gibt es so ganz kurz vor dem Ziel so einen Moment, …
Klar.
… wo alles auseinanderreißt.
Und dann ist ja die Frage, wann ist man quasi erfolgreich genug, gibt es da so ein finales Ziel
oder ist jede Visualisierung im Prinzip immer nur so gut wie man sie gerade braucht?
Ist die Frage, was man damit bezwecken will.
Ja.
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel über die Fischschwärme rede, dann geht es mir häufig darum,
überhaupt erst mal zu vermitteln, dass eben aus vergleichsweise einfachen Regeln sehr komplexes Verhalten entstehen kann.
Wir machen manchmal Fortbildungen für Lehrer zum Beispiel, in denen wir den Prozess,
wie komme ich denn jetzt von ein paar grundlegenden Ideen zu etwas hin,
das am Ende zu so einer Schwarmsimulation führt, indem wir den thematisieren,
damit die das zum Beispiel wieder im Unterricht weitergeben können.
Also das sind ganz viele verschiedenen Ebenen der ursprünglichen Absicht, dann der Metaabsicht,
die Absicht zu vermitteln und so weiter, dann der Metaabsicht zu erklären,
wie macht man denn so was denn im etwas allgemeineren, das verzahnt sich an der Stelle alles irgendwo.
Und ich muss gerade noch mal eine Sache reinbringen, die ein Stück von dem Fischschwarm weggeht,
und zwar wieder ein Stück zurück auch auf die abstrakten Zusammenhänge.
Es gab hier gerade an der TU München in den 60-90er Jahren des vorletzten Jahrhunderts,
also wir reden jetzt von 1860 bis 1890 eine sehr intensive Tradition des mathematischen Modellbaus.
Was ja letztlich auch eine Form der Visualisierung ist.
Und eine der Personen, die da maßgeblich dran beteiligt war, ein sehr bekannter Mathematiker,
der Felix Klein, und der schreibt dann irgendwann mal rückblickend über dieses Modelle bauen,
indem er über die Zeit schreibt, wie damals war auch heute der Zweck des Modells nicht,
die Schwäche der Anschauung auszugleichen, sondern eine lebendige Anschauung überhaupt erst zu schaffen.
Ein Ziel, das vor allem durch das selbst anfertigen von Modellen am besten erreicht wurde.
Und so ähnlich ist das mit den Visualisierungen.
Also wenn ich, also wir haben ja häufig mit unseren Studenten Visualisierungsseminare,
in denen sich die Studenten relativ frei ein Thema suchen, und es geht drum,
sie sollen dazu eine gute Visualisierung erstellen.
Und in dem Prozess des Erstellens des Modells verstehen sie auf einmal die Thematik auf einem viel viel tieferen Niveau.
Und das ist nämlich noch so ein anderer Nebeneffekt der Visualisierung,
Ich würde mal sagen, ich selbst habe an meinen Programmen am meisten gelernt.
Weil ich einfach Probleme so tief durchdringe musste, um überhaupt zu dieser Visualisierung hinzukommen,
dass das eben Forschung für sich genommen schon mal wieder ist.
Und das ist ein Effekt, den man auch in der Form weitergeben kann.
Man schafft sich quasi einen neuen Sinn, um einen Bereich neu erfassen zu können darüber.
Man legt noch mal so eine Lage …
Sinn im mehrfachen Sinne des Wortes, Sinn im Sinne von Sinngebung, aber Sinn auch im Sinne von Wahrnehmungsorgan.
So meinte ich es vor allem.
Also Computer sind für Mathematiker häufig Mikroskop und Teleskop,
mit denen sie Dinge sehen können, die sie so nicht sehen könnten, wenn nicht zwischendrin irgendwo was gerechnet
und dann auf dem Bildschirm dargestellt würde.
Und es ist ja eigentlich auch genau die Sinneswahrnehmung des Menschen, die diese Kernfähigkeit der Abstraktion,
die ja letzten Endes bedeutet, ich kann Dinge auseinanderhalten und schaffe mir meine eigenen Trennungen,
wo beginnt etwas, wo endet etwas, das ist ja diese Abstraktion, das ist ein Baum und da fängt er an und da hört er auf,
das bedeutet, auch hier in der Visualisierung schafft man damit auch neue Begriffe der Abstraktion,
um Dinge voneinander auch vielleicht besser trennen zu können.
Neue Begriffe der Abstraktion und auch neue Möglichkeiten der Intuition.
Also nicht selten wurden mathematische Ergebnisse, wichtige mathematische Ergebnisse gefunden,
nachdem die Leute sich mathematische Visualisierungen zu einem bestimmten Thema angeschaut haben
oder erst mal selbst programmiert haben, dann darüber Dinge sehen konnten,
die vorher ihrem Sinnesorgan nicht zugänglich waren und darüber eine Intuition für neue Effekte aufbauen können.
Es gibt tatsächlich in der Mathematik einen Forschungszweig, der nennt sich experimentelle Mathematik,
die genau versucht, solche Dinge zu kultivieren und Werkzeuge des Experimentierens mit Mathematik zu schaffen,
mit dem man einfach auch mal in größerem Maße Dinge ausprobieren kann.
Und ähnlich wie ein Physiker oder ein Chemiker, der verschiedene Substanzen versucht auf ganz unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen zusammenzumixen,
plötzlich Dinge zusammenzubringen, die auf den ersten Blick scheinbar gar nicht zusammen gehören
und darüber plötzlich Effekte zu sehen, mit denen man vorher nie gerechnet hätte
und die teilweise sehr sehr tief liegen.
Jetzt ist ja hier schon viel über Software gesprochen worden und über Lösungswege, Algorithmen letztlich,
und wir hatten es ja auch ganz zu Beginn schon, dass die Mathematik und die Informatik sehr aneinander stößt.
Wie nahe sind sich denn diese Disziplinen eigentlich wirklich?
Wo macht es Sinn, diese Felder zu trennen, wo sind sie sich denn vielleicht ähnlicher als sie es sein wollen?
Wie nahe ist die Mathematik der Informatik, wie nahe ist die Informatik der Mathematik.
Das kommt, glaube ich, sehr auf die jeweilige Person an, die gerade Mathematik oder Informatik betreibt.
Natürlich kann man Informatik betreiben und dabei relativ wenig Mathematik machen.
Man kann auch Mathematik betreiben und dabei relativ wenig Informatik machen.
Je nachdem in welchem Gebiet man sich gerade bewegt.
Aber es gibt eine Schnittstelle, in der der Overlap so groß ist, dass das eine oder das andere nicht richtig existieren kann.
Und viele Bereiche der Mathematik haben auch schon Informatik betrieben, bevor es überhaupt Computer gab.
Und in dem Sinne ist es eben auch Informatik in einer Richtung zumindest aus der Mathematik raus entstanden,
allerdings auch aus rein pragmatischen Aspekten, wie zum Beispiel Webstühle zu programmieren,
sind in den allerersten Anfängen der Informatik…
Ich würde sagen, das ist eine angenehme Symbiose idealerweise und ich bin immer sehr dagegen, Dinge einfach zu trennen
und schnell zu trennen und zu sagen, bis dahin ist Mathematik und ab da ist es jetzt Informatik.
Also mein ganzes Leben der letzten, ich würde mal sagen, 10 fast 20 Jahre ist ständig ein Mix aus beiden Gebieten
und wenige Ergebnisse, die ich hatte, wären ohne Computerhilfe entstanden
und wenige Programme, die ich geschrieben habe, wären ohne mathematische Hintergründe entstanden.
Ich glaube, so geht es sehr vielen Kollegen gerade hier im Haus.
Wir sind an der Technischen Universität München, in der sich die Mathematik auch wirklich sehr anwendungsbezogen definiert,
was jetzt nicht heißt, dass jeder von uns Anwendungen macht, aber die Schnittstelle Mathematik und Informatik
in gewissem Sinne als eine Einheit zu empfinden ist, glaube ich, eine Philosophie,
die viele hier irgendwo in ihrer TU DNA drin haben.
Und das mag anders sein an Instituten, die nicht dieses T im Namen schon drin haben wie die Technische Universität München.
Und es ist so, mein Werdegang hatte immer ein T im Namen, ich habe also an der TH Darmstadt studiert,
an der KTH dann auch noch einmal promoviert, an der ETA in Zürich war ich
und jetzt bin ich hier an der TU München, also dieses T zieht sich bei mir immer durch
und das heißt auch immer, das eine Gebiet mit dem anderen in Verbindung zu bringen.
Trotzdem ist es ja hier, glaube ich, auch ein Teilfeld der Forschung, computergerechte Strukturierung von Geometrie herzustellen.
Was muss man sich darunter vorstellen, was wird denn dem Computer gerecht und was muss sozusagen dann …
Es spielen viele Dinge zusammen.
Also eine lange Zeit, ist jetzt im Moment nicht mehr so das aktuellste Forschungsthema bei mir,
eine lange Zeit habe ich mich mit sogenannter dynamischer Geometrie beschäftigt.
Idee ist, Sie malen eine geometrische Konstellation auf dem Rechner, zum Beispiel den Satz von Pythagoras oder was ähnliches
und ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, ich möchte immer solche Experimentierfelder schaffen,
das heißt, ich möchte nicht nur ein Bild haben, sondern ich möchte nachher an die Punkte drangehen
und daran auch bewegen können.
Es soll parametrisierbar sein.
Mehrdimensional.
Mehrdimensional ist gar nicht mal, also ist auch wichtig, aber …
Ist eher zwangsläufig in dem Moment, wo man mehrere Parameter eingibt.
Der Parameterraum ist natürlich vieldimensional.
Ja, das meinte ich.
Jetzt kommt aber was ganz gemeines rein.
Dieses Gebiet der dynamischen Geometrie ist als Forschungsrichtung so in den 80er Jahren letzten Jahrhunderts entstanden,
80er, 90er und da gab es zum Beispiel immer ein ganz fundamentales Problem
und die Leute haben das bezeichnet als das Problem der springenden Punkte.
Also da hat man wirklich einen springenden Punkt im wörtlichen Sinne.
Und zwar wenn ich jetzt was geometrisch konstruiere und das parametrisiere,
jetzt bitte ich alle Leute, die uns hier zuhören, sich mal einfach einen Kreis und eine Gerade vorzustellen.
Der Kreis und die Gerade sollen sich jetzt mal schneiden und Sie stellen sich jetzt mal vor,
Sie zeichnen einen der beiden Schnittpunkte ein.
Jetzt fangen Sie an, an dem Kreis und der Geraden rumzubewegen und dieser Schnittpunkt soll halt immer schön mitbewegt werden.
Moment mal, dieser Schnittpunkt, es gibt ja zwei dieser Schnittpunkte.
Ein Kreis und eine Gerade die haben zwei Schnittpunkte und in jedem Moment muss der Computer entscheiden,
welchen Schnittpunkt meine ich denn jetzt eigentlich von den beiden,
weil sonst hüpft auf einmal der Punkt von dem einen Schnittpunkt auf den anderen.
Verrückterweise ist das ein richtiges Problem, so banal es erscheint.
Und alle Programme der frühen dynamischen Geometrie haben unter dem Problem gelitten
und viele CAD Systeme machen das heute noch, dass, wenn eine Konstruktion zu komplex wird,
ich an Parametern spiele, dass dann plötzlich ein Element der Konstruktion komplett unmotiviert von einer Stelle zur anderen hüpft.
Wenn man das einer mathematischen Analyse unterzieht, stellt man auf einmal fest,
man hat es mit Räumen von analytischen Funktionen zu tun, denen man nur über sogenannte komplexe Zahlen richtig zu Leibe rücken kann
und indem man das Ganze in einen viel höher dimensionalen Umgebungsraum einbettet,
wo man dann um sogenannte Singularitäten, die hier auftreten, dann einen großen Umweg macht,
um die einzelnen Objekte immer auseinanderzuhalten.
Und tatsächlich ist man da ein ganzes Stück in tiefer Funktionentheorie gelandet,
um dieses Problem, was einem so banal erscheint, in den Griff zu kriegen.
Und kann sogar beweisen, das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, das in den Griff zu kriegen.
Und das ist jetzt zum Beispiel so eine Schlüsselstelle, wo man wirklich ganz gehörig in die mathematische Trickkiste greifen muss,
um etwas, einem erst mal als eine ganz einfache Aufgabe erscheint, endgültig in den Griff zu kriegen.
Und das ist zum Beispiel eine Leistung hier von der Forschungsarbeit, die wir hier im Rahmen von den verschiedenen Visualisierungsprojekten gemacht haben,
dass wir das einfach ein für allemal richtig in den Griff bekommen haben
und dann geht die Fragestellung natürlich weiter, wenn man es im Griff hat,
dann wie schwierig ist denn das dann algorithmisch umzusetzen?
Und dann stellt man fest, dass, wenn man es ganz ganz richtig machen will,
dass das Ganze dann allerdings beweisbar schwierig wird.
Und dann ist man wieder in der Klasse der harten Probleme mit drin, die ich vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen habe,
und ja, es ist letztlich mathematische Grundlagenforschung, die man betreibt,
um ein scheinbar banales Visualisierungsproblem in den Griff zu kriegen und es führt kein Weg dran vorbei.
Also wenn man es richtig macht, geht es nur so.
Das heißt, wenn die CAD Software keine springenden Punkte haben will…
…braucht sie komplexe Zahlen.
Ich grübele schon die ganze Zeit über den Ursprung dieses Begriffs springender Punkt, aber …
Er kommt ursprünglich woanders her der Begriff.
Aber es ist tatsächlich so, okay, wir haben hier immer wieder Geschichten.
In den 90er Jahren haben wir mal auf einer Computermesse ausgestellt, der Orbit in Basel
und sind dann mal von einem CAD Stand zum anderen gegangen und erst mal war eine Frage,
gibt es überhaupt vernünftig parametrisierte CAD Systeme, ein paar haben wir gefunden
und die, die wir gefunden hatten, hatten wir innerhalb von Größenordnung fünf Minuten,
wenn wir das Benutzerinterface verstanden hatten, dann an der Stelle, wo bei denen dann die Objekte gesprungen sind.
Also kein einziges dieser Systeme war in der Lage, eine geringfügig mathematisch anspruchsvolle …
In welchem Jahr war das noch so?
Das war, Moment ich muss nachrechnen, 96, 97, 98 um den Dreh rum.
Ich befürchte, die Bilanz ist heute nicht schrecklich viel besser.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen, inwiefern solche Erkenntnisse halt auch wirklich in die Softwareentwicklung Einfluss hat.
Teilweise ja.
Also ich habe damals auch auf Konferenzen mit Leuten geredet, die CAD Systeme erstellt haben
aus industrieller professioneller Seite und ein paar haben zumindest ernsthaft in Erwägung gezogen,
an der Stelle auf einen anderen Rechenkern umzustellen und wir haben zumindest mal diskutiert,
was sind denn die Möglichkeiten und Konsequenzen.
Ob sie es am Ende tatsächlich gemacht haben, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen,
aber zumindest das Problembewusstsein, das häufig nicht da war,
das war dann zumindest zu dem Zeitpunkt in einigen Köpfen deutlich besser.
Da ist immer die Frage, wie groß ist das Risiko.
Also ich meine, wenn jetzt sozusagen die maximale Auswirkung ist, das zittert ein bisschen auf dem Bildschirm, aber am Ende…
Geht nicht um zittern.
Also wenn das das einzige wäre, also wenn man sozusagen nur so eine fehlerhafte,
also eine sekundäre optische Störung erzeugen würde, das ist ja das eine.
Aber wenn ich sage, ich mache aber jetzt hier irgendwie einen Kraftwerksbau und wenn ich das nicht sicherstellen kann,
dass das jetzt auch wirklich gelöst ist in allen Fällen, trete ich mir unter Umständen einen Fehler ein,
einen konstruktionellen Fehler, der halt die Sicherheit des ganzen Projektes riskieren kann.
Diskontinuitäten sind ein Problem, mit dem man immer wieder in der Informatik zu kämpfen hat.
Es gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob die Geschichte wahr oder nur gut erfunden ist,
aber es gibt angeblich diesen Düsenjet, der sich über dem Äquator plötzlich auf den Rücken gedreht hat,
weil irgendwo ein Vorzeichenfehler in der Steuerlogik war, die einfach mit dem Übergang über den Äquator nicht umgehen konnte
und ein Vorzeichen umgeflippt hat und von nicht sehr sehr unterschiedlicher Art sind diese Probleme,
die es dann in der konstruktiven Geometrie gibt, dann auch.
Also letztlich geht es um richtige Wahl von Vorzeichen dabei.
Ist das Testing ein Problem in der Softwareentwicklung.
Man testet halt nicht alle Fälle, sondern nur eben die, die erst mal offensichtlich erscheinen
oder die einzigen, an die man denkt, aber ein mathematisches Modell vielleicht herbeizuziehen,
was in irgendeiner Form sicherstellen kann, dass ich auch alle Fälle teste, die ich testen müsste,
das könnte ja an der Stelle auch schon helfen.
Wobei an der Stell noch dazukommt, dass es an der Stelle um kontinuierliche Übergänge geht.
Und es zumindest gar nicht mal diese endliche Anzahl von Fällen gibt.
Und da kommt dann wieder die Mathematik rein, wie reduziert man so ein Problem letztlich auf eine endliche Anzahl von Fällen?
Also auch da allein um ein Testszenario gescheit zu machen, braucht man wieder Mathematik,
um einfach darüber Auskunft zu geben, wenn ich nur das und das und das abgetestet habe,
dann habe ich das auch in seiner Gesamtheit, wenn der Rest wenigstens stimmt.
Also beweisbar korrekte Software ist wiederum ein Forschungsgebiet sowohl der praktischen als auch der theoretischen Informatik.
Also dass da einiges im Argen liegt, das merke ich immer wieder, wenn mir Programme mir irgendwelche Karten
und meine eigene Position anzeigen und ich stelle wieder fest, dass ich 500 Kilometer südlich von Nigeria irgendwo im Wasser treibe.
Schön dort, sehr schön dort.
Schön dort und vor allem halt Koordinate 0;0, da weiß man halt schon wieder,
da ist irgendwas ganz gründlich schief gelaufen, an welcher Stelle auch immer.
Aber jetzt gerade noch mal ganz kurz zum Thema Software entwerfen.
Ich schreibe ja selbst auch sehr viel Software und ein großes Problem, mit dem man als Softwareentwickler ständig zu kämpfen hat,
ist, dass man selbst sein Programm immer nur in den Grenzen testet, in denen man es sich selbst vorstellt.
Sogar manchmal intuitiv, um die Schwachstellen einen Bogen drumherum macht,
weil man einfach weiß, ah okay da wird es vielleicht gar nicht so funktionieren
und irgendwas ganz im Hinterkopf sagt einem, will ich gar nicht erst testen,
auch da ist es dann wieder ein ganz bewusster Akt des formalen Denkens, genau das nicht zu tun.
Und da stecken in der Softwareentwicklung einige Fallen, in die man sehr schnell reinlaufen kann.
Gibt ja auch so eine eigene Disziplin in der Informatik hin zu beweisbarer Software.
Genau.
Die halt mathematisch dann auch wirklich nachweisen kann, dass sie in allen Fällen richtig rechnet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt hier …
Unter bestimmten Prämissen gibt es…
Unter bestimmten Prämissen.
Im Informatikdepartement gibt es einige Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen.
Und überschneidet sich das so mit Ihrer Forschung in gewisser Hinsicht?
Also ich schreibe keine beweisbar korrekte Software in dem strengen Sinne.
Ich habe mich aber eine ganze Weile mit automatischen Beweisen aus Software heraus beschäftigt.
Das war tatsächlich übrigens der ganz ursprüngliche Motivationspunkt für diese ganzen dynamischen Geometriesachen.
Zu Zeiten von meiner Dissertation habe ich automatische Beweise geometrischer Sätze Algorithmen dafür entworfen
und dafür wollte ich ein Eingabeinterface.
Also man zeichnet zum Beispiel den Satz von Pythagoras hin, soll auf einen Knopf drücken
und dann möchte man einen Beweis für das Theorem geliefert bekommen.
Und das war der Ursprung für diese ganzen dynamischen Geometriesachen, mit denen ich mich beschäftigt habe
und die kamen ursprünglich aus dem Thema automatisches Beweisen.
Was übrigens dann, um den Bogen jetzt ganz groß rund zu schließen,
ursprünglich aus den Sachen mit den Nichtrealisierbarkeitsbeweisen für die Vielflächen in vier Dimensionen,
was da wiederum irgendwo seinen Ursprung mit hat.
Also hängt alles irgendwo zusammen, ist aber, wenn man es von außen anschaut, vielleicht etwas diskontinuierlicher
als es dann in der eigenen Biografie letztlich ist.
Ein Anlass, nicht der einzige, aber ein Anlass, hier das Gespräch mal zu suchen, ist ja,
dass Sie gerade vom DFG und Stifterverband den Kommunikatorpreis vermittelt bekommen haben.
Da geht es natürlich vor allem um die Kommunikation dieses Wissens in viele Bereiche.
Und ja, da wird ja so einiges erwähnt, abgesehen von der Kerntätigkeit hier am Lehrstuhl, die wir schon gemacht haben,
finden ja hier auch noch ein paar andere Sachen statt.
Gerade eben war ich in einer kleinen Ausstellung hier unten im Gebäude des IX Quadrat,
wo man schon allerlei, also wo es handgreiflich wurde, also wo man quasi Visualisierung in konkreten Körpern,
Objekten, aber halt auch Bildern gesehen hat und auch eben in solchen parametrisierbaren Sachen.
Sie haben das ja schon erwähnt, so Kommunikation und das Weiterreichen dieses Wissens
und auch das Zugänglichmachen von Mathematik das ist so ein bisschen auch Ihr Steckenpferd.
Was findet da noch alles statt, um das gut kommunizieren zu können, was hilft?
Das ist jetzt eine Sache, mit der ich mich tatsächlich schon eine ganze Weile beschäftige.
Also die Ursprünge gehen bis auf 86 zurück, wo ich für eine Symmetrieausstellung in Darmstadt schon erste Software geschrieben habe,
hier am Campus habe ich jetzt unsere Mathematikausstellung vor rund 20 Jahren aufgemacht
und der Ansatz dabei ist eigentlich immer der, dass man Dinge zugänglich machen möchte,
dass man interessante Dinge zugänglich machen möchte.
Also eine wichtige Sache bei uns in der Ausstellung im IX Quadrat, übrigens man spricht es X-Quadrat aus.
Oh, Entschuldigung.
Nicht I X-Quadrat.
Ein wichtiger Punkt dabei ist, Phänomene zu suchen, die verstehbar genug sind,
um damit einen interessanten Dialog über die Objekte hervorrufen zu können.
Und tatsächlich die Ausstellung, wie wir sie unten haben, die ist so aufgebaut,
dass es verschiedene Pfade durch die Exponate gibt, die unterschiedlichste Zusammenhänge rausholen können.
Also ein großer Teil geht um das Thema Symmetrie.
Symmetrie ist ein wunderbares Thema, über das man ganz toll mit Leuten reden kann,
die ansonsten sagen, ich habe mit Mathematik gar nicht so schrecklich viel am Hut
und die Ausstellung ist so gemacht, dass man da sowohl mit einem Kindergartenkind
als auch mit einem Oberstufenschüler als auch mit einem Gastwissenschaftler einen interessanten Dialog darüber führen kann.
Und dazu sind die Phänomene halt sehr gezielt rausgesucht.
Und die Ausstellung ist, ich sage jetzt mal so rum, ziemlich designed darauf hin.
Und ein typischer Effekt, den wir haben, dass die Leute rausgehen aus dem Raum und sagen,
Mensch der Raum ist ja von innen viel größer als von außen.
Weil eigentlich was wir gemacht haben ist, Räume im Kopf zu öffnen, in die die Leute dann eintauchen können.
Also rund 50 Exponate gibt es da unten, dann gibt es aber noch verschiedene andere Projekte.
Es gibt diverse Wissenschaftskommunikationsapps, in der verschiedene Effekte auch wieder dargestellt werden.
Wobei ich immer versuche, Computer nur dann einzusetzen, wenn man wirklich um das Digitale nicht drum herum kommt.
Also Effekte, die man anfassen kann, die soll man eben auch anfassen können,
aber der Anschauungsraum reicht halt nur bis zu einem gewissen Punkt und dann ist der Computereinsatz was ganz wichtiges.
Dann gibt es diverse Wanderausstellungen, Kooperationen mit dem Deutschen Museum,
Kooperation mit dem Mathemuseum MoMa in New York.
Und viele Dinge, wo man sich immer wieder Sachen ausdenkt, wie man denn Leute für Mathematik oder im Allgemeinen auch für Wissenschaft begeistern kann.
Und da kann ich gerne noch was zu den verschiedenen Ansätzen sagen, was man damit machen kann.
Gelingt denn das?
Ja, oft.
Oft.
Nicht immer.
Also wer ist denn so die Zielgruppe der Überlegungen?
Ich. Ich bin ein Spielkind, also ich freue mich selbst an Phänomenen.
Und Dinge, an denen man selbst Spaß hat, die lassen sich auch selbst wieder gut weitergeben.
Und tatsächlich ist die Zielgruppe letztlich besteht aus Personen, die entweder sagen,
ich habe mit Mathematik gar nicht so schrecklich viel am Hut oder aus Leuten, die sagen,
eigentlich interessiert mich Mathematik, lass mich doch mal ein bisschen mehr erfahren,
aber auch Leute, die sagen, ich kenne mich total gut in Mathematik aus,
zeig mir doch mal was neues interessantes, was ich noch nicht kenne.
Also die Zielgruppe ist erschreckend breit.
Über die Apps hat sich zum Beispiel auch noch eine ganz neue Zielgruppe aufgetan,
ich habe eine App, die ist so an der Schnittstelle von Mathematik zu Kunst
und Kunstschaffende, insbesondere wenn es in den Bereich Grafikdesign reingeht,
sind ja auch häufig sehr formal denkende Menschen, trotz aller Kreativität, die in Kunst drinsteckt
und die kommen häufig zu mir und sagen, Mensch ich hätte gar nicht gewusst,
dass in mir auch eine mathematische Seite drin steckt und deine Apps haben mir das irgendwo aufgeschlossen.
Und Augenöffner sein, das ist vielleicht die wichtigste Message, die in den ganzen Dingen mit rüberkommt.
Es gibt ja seit einiger Zeit diesen Kunsttrend, würde ich es mal nennen, der generativen Kunst.
Also sowohl was Akustik betrifft als auch Visualisierung betrifft., das geht sehr weit,
das ist ja dann tatsächlich auch eine Interessante Schnittstelle zu Ihrer Arbeit.
Das ist eine direkte Schnittstelle zur Mathematik, nicht unbedingt zu meiner Arbeit,
weil ich nur sehr indirekt generative Kunst betreibe.
Ich habe vorhin gesagt, in den Apps, die ich mache, geht es mir häufig darum,
dass die Spielregeln möglichst klar sind.
Und was ich machen möchte, ich verstehe mich häufig als ein Werkzeugmacher,
der den Benutzern Software oder Objekte an die Hand gibt, die praktisch Dinge ermöglicht,
die man ohne das Werkzeug nicht tun könnte.
Und es gibt viele andere Apps in Richtung generative Kunst, in denen man mit der App interagiert,
aber letztlich nicht weiß, was die App jetzt eigentlich aus dem gemacht hat, was ich jetzt da reingegeben habe.
Da spielt dann auch ganz häufig Zufall eine Rolle und ähnliches.
Ich versuche Dinge zu machen, in denen die Regeln extrem klar snid und sich darüber aber dann ein ganzer Horizont von Möglichkeiten ergibt.
Wie zum Beispiel Flächenornamente oder Rosettenornamente oder ähnliches zu zeichnen.
Und genau diese Spielart, dass die Regeln sehr klar sind und trotzdem Dinge entstehen,
mit denen ich gar nicht gerechnet hätte, das ist sehr spannend, dass dann an kreative Leute zu geben.
Das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich, wie wenn man Flöte in einem Raum mit einem guten Echo spielt.
Also man hat eine Flöte und macht etwas und plötzlich kommt von den Wänden das zurück, was man gerade selbst gemacht hat
und man kommt mit sich selbst in Interaktion dabei nach bestimmten Regeln,
und dabei kann sehr interessante und gute Musik entstehen.
Und ähnlich kann passieren, wenn man in einer App, die symmetrisch widerspiegelt,
was man gerade gemacht hat, kann plötzlich ein Dialog mit sich selbst entstehen,
der einen über das hinausführt, was man nur mit Stift und Papier sonst gemacht hätte.
Will nicht sagen, tun könnte, weil man könnte es mit sehr viel Mühe,
aber man wäre dann nicht so in diesem kreativen Fluss drin.
Und um das zu machen, auch wieder ein Haufen Mathematik hinten dran.
Ich akzeptiere diese Trennung zwischen hier, ich mache ja nur das Werkzeug und in dem Moment,
wo das Werkzeug dann von jemandem benutzt wird, dann ist es auf einmal Kunst so,
da gehe ich nur begrenzt mit, zumal ich ja ohnehin …
Weil oft auch, ich meine, hat natürlich ein bisschen was mit dem Begriffsverständnis für Kunst zu tun,
was ist das eigentlich, wo fängt es an, wo hört es auf, aber sicherlich ohne Zweifel ist der Kunstprozess immer einer,
der auch so eine schöpferische Komponente hat, die zwangsläufig am status quo ansetzt,
das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man auch Werkzeug schafft, was überhaupt erst eine Visualisierung,
eine parametrisierte Betrachtung von etwas, was ja quasi auch wieder eine neuartige Verarbeitung von Daten ist
und damit eben was neues schafft, dann kann ja das Werkzeug selbst ja auch schon die Kunst sein.
Also gerade in dem Moment, wo der Computer auch Einzug gehalten hat in die Kunstwelt,
sind ja oft Dinge schon bestaunt worden und das sicherlich auch zurecht.
Wo man vielleicht auch heutiger Perspektive relativ einfache Dinge überhaupt erst mal zusammengemacht hat,
weil diese Kombinatorik, diese generative Tätigkeit, dieses Visualisieren letzten Endes unterschiedlicher Eingabedinge,
und wenn es erst mal nur so ganz grundlegende Sachen waren am Anfang wie,
man hat da ein Mikrofon und dann wird halt die akustische Information in eine visuelle Information übersetzt,
auch das ist ja schon ein künstlerischer Prozess, von daher erscheint mir hier der Übergang doch sehr fließend zu sein.
Ich muss auf einen Satz, den Sie eben eingeleitet haben, kurz zu sprechen kommen.
Sie haben eben gesagt, ich mache ja nur das Werkzeug, und dieses nur würde ich massiv rausstreichen.
Ja.
Weil…
Das war ja auch nur überspitzt formuliert. Nur.
Klar. Ein Instrumentenbauer ist ein Künstler und ein Artefakt so zu schaffen,
dass daraus etwas entsteht, mit dem Kreativität möglich ist, ist ein kreativer Prozess in sich selbst.
Und ich verbringe viel Zeit damit, mir darüber Gedanken zu machen, wie ich den möglichst perfekten Strich auf einem Zeichenprogramm machen kann,
der sich möglichst natürlich oder sogar übernatürlich anfühlt.
Und da ist dann im Hintergrund wieder jede Menge Algorithmik, und die gibt aber dann wiederum anderen Leuten die Möglichkeit,
Dinge zu machen, die mehr sind als ich jemals könnte und mehr sind als Sie jemals ohne die Programme könnten.
Und es gibt diesen einen Grafikdesigner, Kaligrafen, Seb Lester aus Großbritannien,
der hat mit meiner Symmetrie-App wahrscheinlich die komplexesten Buchstaben gemalt,
die jemals in der Menschheitsgeschichte überhaupt irgendwo gezeichnet wurden,
weil einfach an der Stelle seine Fähigkeiten plus den Möglichkeiten des Programms zusammengekommen sind,
zu etwas, was einfach viel mehr ist als was sowohl er als auch ich könnte.
Das finde ich toll, das macht wahnsinnig Spaß.
Und jetzt gerade über diese Apps auf der Schnittstelle von Mathematik zu Kunst,
Mathematik und Musik bin ich mit Leuten in Kontakt gekommen,
die wirklich zu den bereicherndsten Begegnungen hatte und ich meine jetzt, intellektuell bereichernd,
die ich bisher hatte und gerade diese Grenzbereiche von Wissenschaft zu Gebieten,
die erst mal gar nicht wissenschaftlich erscheinen, auszuloten, ist ein unglaublich spannender Prozess.
Da die Lehre ja hier so eine besondere Bedeutung hat, würde mich natürlich jetzt auch noch mal interessieren,
wie denn jetzt die Pandemie hier vielleicht die Arbeit beeinflusst hat.
Ich bin mir sicher, das wird sie getan haben.
Gerade wenn man so eine Liebe zu Werkzeugen hat und gerne die Dinge automatisiert haben möchte
und vielleicht auch gut visualisiert haben möchte, wie hat sich denn das hier ausgewirkt auf die Lehre?
Ich rede jetzt einfach mal von mir ganz persönlich.
Die letzten zwei Jahre waren wahrscheinlich mithin bezüglich Lehre die arbeitsreichsten, die ich je hatte.
Und gleichzeitig war die Pandemiesituation eine gewissen Steilvorlage für unsere Zunft der Visualisierung.
Weil man steht jetzt plötzlich da und das, was man schon immer betrieben hat,
nämlich Inhalte digital zugänglich zu machen, wird auf einmal absolut notwendig, um einfach unterrichten zu können.
Ich habe für mich selbst dabei das Ziel gehabt, also ich unterrichte sehr gerne
und Lehre ist mir selbst eine heilige Aufgabe, und ich mache normalerweise auch sehr gute und schöne Livevorlesungen
und ich habe mir vorgenommen, in den Videocasts, die ich zu meinen Livevorlesungen jetzt gemacht habe,
oder die diese ersetzen sollten, sollte nichts fehlen, was sonst auch in der Vorlesung drin ist.
Was am Ende dazu geführt hat, dass ich Filme produziert habe, in denen eine Stunde Video im Film ungefähr 17 Stunden Arbeit bedeuten,
mit zuerst Konzeptbuch erstellen, letztlich eine Art Drehbuch erstellen, Visualisierungen dafür schreiben,
das ganze Zeug selbst aufnehmen, selbst zusammenschneiden, wo aber am Ende was rausgekommen ist,
an dem ich selbst auch wirklich Spaß habe und mir selbst auch gerne anschaue.
Wo eben genau diese Schnittstelle von formalem Zugang, visuellem Zugang,
erklären auf sehr vielen verschiedenen Ebenen, die ganze Zeit in den Videos durchgezogen wird.
Und die Studenten haben ihren Spaß dran.
Also wir haben jetzt zweimal in Folge dafür Lehrauszeichnungen hier von der Fakultät bekommen
und ich habe viele Studenten gehört, die gesagt haben, bitte die Videos auf keinen Fall nach der Pandemie abschaffen,
die müssen weiter existieren und die Lehre muss sich ein Stück auch mit an den Medien mit orientieren.
Ich finde das ein sehr spannendes Thema.
Macht endlos viel Arbeit, aber macht auch endlos viel Spaß.
Wie digital ist denn die Lehre hier schon?
Was ist hier?
Also hier in dem Lehrstuhl oder an der Fakultät.
Hier am Lehrstuhl, also die letzten zwei Semester oder drei Semester haben wir voll digital durchgezogen.
Im Moment geht es halt wieder ein Stück zurück in Richtung Hybridformate.
Ich selbst werde sehr wahrscheinlich die Videos, die ich jetzt in der Zeit erstellt habe,
auch für zukünftige Unterrichtsjahre verwenden und mehr und mehr auf inverted classroom, flipped classroom umstellen,
in dem es halt dann wirklich darum geht, dass die Studenten sich die Videos mit all ihren Vorteilen,
und ein riesiger Vorteil von einem Video ist die Pausetaste und die Rewindtaste und die Stopptaste.
Und überhaupt, dass ich Tasten habe, an denen ich das Ganze auch, wenn ich es mag,
morgens um 6 oder nachts um 12 anschalten kann, wenn ich am aufnahmefähigsten dazu bin.
Und die Rolle des Unterrichtenden ist dann letztlich „nur noch“, verbleibende Fragen zu klären.
Und das ist ja der eigentlich spannende Teil und das sollte man dann in Präsenz,
wenn das wieder möglich wird, in Präsenzeinheiten machen.
Also ich denke, wir werden an ganz vielen Stellen unsere Lehre überdenken müssen,
weil wir einfach wirklich viel dazu gelernt haben über die letzten drei Semester.
Und ich bin wirklich, auch wenn es sehr viel Arbeit war, froh über die Erfahrung,
froh auch darum zu wissen, wieviel Arbeit es ist, bestimmte Sachen in einem bestimmten Qualitätsniveau herzustellen,
und ja man hat jede Menge Techniken gelernt und auch viele Sachen noch mal anders pädagogisch überdacht.
Was denn zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel den Stellenwert von Visualisierungen, jetzt in meinem ganz konkreten Fall.
Während ich Visualisierungen in der Präsenzlehre immer mehr oder weniger vollkommen nebenbei praktisch eingesetzt habe.
Ich hatte die Dinger so und so auf dem Computer und habe sie, wenn immer es sich im Unterricht angeboten hat,
einfach mit rausgenommen und spontan im Unterricht mit verwendet.
So wie man an den Modellschrank geht und rausgreift.
Plötzlich musste man diese Visualisierungen in ganz gezielter Art und Weise konkret in einen vorgeplanten Fluss einbinden.
Und dann auch irgendwo die Balance halten zwischen visualisierten und formalen
und über die Brücken mehr Gedanken sich machen und man musste dabei viele der Rollen,
die die Visualisierung während dem normalen Unterricht spielt,
nämlich gerade zum Beispiel auf Fragen von Studenten reagieren zu können und zu sagen,
jetzt schaue dir das doch mal da und da so und so an, dann siehst du wie sich das verhält,
das vorauszuahnen und praktisch die Fragen im eigenen Video irgendwo auch intern vorwegzunehmen
und dann ohne die Frage explizit zu stellen, die Frage zu beantworten und seine Erklärungen besser zu machen.
Also das Erstellen der Videos war ein sehr starker Vorgang des Bewusstmachens von dem,
was erzählt man da jetzt eigentlich?
Und wieviel wird davon bleiben?
Also ich meine, manches war natürlich jetzt in dieser Zeit zwangsläufig.
Voraussagen über die Zukunft sind immer eine ziemlich unsichere Angelegenheit.
Von daher muss man schauen, wieviel davon bleibt.
Ich würde sagen, bei mir wird eine Menge davon bleiben, weil ich einfach selbst meine Freude daran habe.
Es ist letztlich auch ein Stück eine Manifestierung von Dingen, die wir ohnehin schon gemacht haben.
Also die Lehre war ja auch in Zeiten vor der Pandemie schon zu großen Teilen digital unterstützt.
Also es gab immer schon einen blended learning, in dem eben genau diese Mikrolaboratorien
zum Beispiel auf dem Portal mathevital gesammelt wurden, in dem es dann begleitend zu den Vorlesungen,
die ich gemacht habe, und auch begleitend zu Vorlesungen einiger Kollegen Materialsammlungen gab,
in denen die Studenten zu Hause noch mal an eben genau diesen passend gebauten Mikrolaboratorien experimentieren konnten
zum aktuellen Vorlesungsstoff.
Also meine lineare Algebra die ist schon seit, ja Moment, mathevital gibt es seit 2008,
seit 2008 massivst digital unterstützt, dazu kommen die Visualisierungen,
die ich so und so in der Vorlesung selbst verwendet habe.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Bereich, der über die Jahre gewachsen ist und in dem immer mehr dazu kommt.
Und in gewissem Sinne waren jetzt die letzten drei Semester so eine Art Konsolidierung von dem,
was ohnehin da war.
Also von daher in gewissem Sinne, so neu ist es nicht, das Ganze aber dann trotzdem in Drehbuch und in Schnitt
und man steht ja dann selbst auch da und nimmt sich selbst mit auf mit dem Handy
und muss die ganze Zeit irgendwo präsent sein, wie jetzt hier in dem Podcast und möglichst vivant irgendwo reden
und die Leute gefühlt irgendwo dabei halten, das muss man erst mal lernen,
und das war bestimmt ein Prozess des Neulernens an der Stelle.
Ich war dann am Ende überrascht, also normalerweise, wenn ich meine letzte Vorlesungsstunde mache,
dann überkommt mich so ein kleiner Moment der Rührung, dass man jetzt diesen Studentenpool jetzt irgendwo ins nächste Semester entlässt.
Und in der Pandemiezeit ist das soweit gewachsen, dass ich zu meinem Handy,
das dann vor mir stand, ein so intimes dahinter sind jetzt die Studenten-Verhältnis aufgebaut hatte,
dass die letzte Stunde der Vorlesung dann ganz genauso war und ich gedacht habe,
Mensch das ist jetzt aber wirklich komisch, dass du jetzt leicht angerührt bist davon,
dass du jetzt in dem Format deine letzte Stunde gibst und ich glaube, das ist dann ein ganz gutes Gefühl, wenn einem das passiert.
Ist schon mal ein ganz gutes Zeichen.
Ich hatte mich hier im Forschergeist 22 schon vor sechs Jahren mit Jürgen Hanke unterhalten,
der ja in seinem Lehrstuhl, wo es um Englisch geht, ja dasselbe Prinzip des flipped classroom schon lange lange Zeit durchzieht.
Du die interessanteste Erkenntnis, die ich an dem Tag hatte, war, dass sein Büro eigentlich nur noch ein Kamerastudio zu sein schien.
Jetzt wenn hier alle zurückkehren, könnte ich mir vorstellen, könnten diverse Umbaumaßnahmen eingeleitet werden,
um auch ähnliches auch hier zu machen.
Wir haben gerade letzte Woche im Mitarbeiterseminar genau darüber geredet,
was wir eigentlich jetzt neuerdings für Räume bräuchten.
Wobei das ist jetzt, glaube ich, ein pandemiespezifischer Effekt, die Kollegen, die das sehr ernsthaft betreiben,
und es gibt ja einige an der Fakultät, die das sehr ernsthaft betreiben, die haben sich mittlerweile halt zu Hause ihr Videostudio aufgebaut
und mit den jeweiligen Gegebenheiten das möglichst beste daraus gemacht
und auch an ihre jeweilige Person angepasst.
Also wir haben hier einen Kollegen, der Tim Hoffmann, der hat zu Hause wirklich seine komplette Greenscreen,
mehrere Kameramischpulte, Einspielmöglichkeiten, in dem er wirklich sehr virtuos mit all diesen Möglichkeiten umgehen kann.
Bei mir ist es zum Beispiel ein ganz bewusst privat gewählter Rahmen,
ich sitze immer in meiner Wohnzimmerecke, mit meiner Lampe im Hintergrund
und da hat sich auch mittlerweile so ein gewisses Corporate Identity aufgebaut.
Farbige Beleuchtung ein bisschen im Hintergrund, damit man nicht ganz so blass im Gesicht ausschaut und alles mögliche.
Und tatsächlich glaube ich, jetzt das Aufbauen von Studiosituationen hier im Institut,
das wird insbesondere für die Kollegen auch interessant sein,
die das vielleicht bisher jetzt gerade auch über die letzten Jahre noch nicht so exzessiv gemacht haben.
Und dass man da einfach Möglichkeiten schafft und auch einiges an Knowhow weitergibt.
Spannendes Thema.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das über die nächsten Jahre weitergeht.
Ich glaube, dass die drei Semester die Lehre nachhaltig verändert haben.
Ja, ich denke, jetzt haben wir alle Themen angesprochen, die sich jetzt erst mal so aufgedrängt haben.
Ich denke, dass gerade die Lehre noch so auch einen hohen Wandlungsbedarf hat,
dass also einfach diese neuen Wege auch absolut überfällig gewesen sind
und auch, sagen wir mal, eine sehr viel höhere Beteiligung, sehr viel höhere Inklusion auch letzten Endes sicherstellen kann.
Dieses, wann schaue ich mir etwas an, wo ich es am besten aufnehmen kann, das trägt ja dazu bei.
Also ich befürchte, dass folgendes passiert bzw. passiert ist,
die Lehre, die wir jetzt zum Beispiel über die letzten drei Semester gegeben haben,
die wird bei einigen Studenten sehr positive Effekte haben und bei anderen Studenten vielleicht sogar auch sehr negative Effekte.
Und das mag jetzt genau umgekehrt sein, wie man es sonst im normalen classroom hat.
Und ich glaube tatsächlich, dass ein vernünftiges Miteinander der verschiedenen Formate etwas ist,
wo man die nächsten Jahre drauf zuarbeiten sollte.
Weil ich glaube, wir haben es immer bei den Studenten mit Individuen zu tun und jeder ist anders.
Der eine nimmt besser auf, wenn er sich etwas selbst an einem Video erarbeitet,
der andere bekommt es wirklich gerne vorgetragen und arbeitet das Ganze dann nach.
Und ich glaube, die Vielfalt der Formate ist etwas, das für die nächste Zeit sehr wichtig werden wird.
Ja, Herr Richter-Gebert, jetzt fällt mir nichts mehr ein, was ich noch fragen kann.
Mir hat es Spaß gemacht, fand es total entspannend.
Das hat mir auch…
Ich kann ja jetzt fragen.
Dann dauert es ja noch länger.
Ich bedanke mich…
Ich mich auch.
…für das Gespräch und bedanke mich fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist.
Das war es für heute und wir hören uns dann bald wieder.
Tschüss und bis bald.